i'm rebecca ritters welcome to the
program
u.s president joe biden will travel to
kentucky on wednesday to witness for
himself the devastation caused by a
swarm of tornadoes the state's governor
said people there had been through
unspeakable trauma the twisters hit
kentucky and other southeastern states
at the weekend at least 74 people have
died and more than 100 are still missing
officials warn residents could be
without heat water and or and
electricity in freezing temperatures for
weeks in mayfield one of the hardest hit
towns survivors are assessing the damage
of kentucky's worst storm on record
this is this is my daddy's box
this is my daddy's box it had all of his
little things that i have nothing will
ever take these memories away memories
as the dust slowly settles teresa
herndon is counting her blessings
the lord works in mysterious ways
and about two and a half three weeks ago
my daughter came in and she said mother
we're buying new tickets to a blue man
group in las vegas on friday
december the 10th
that night disaster struck in her
hometown of mayfield kentucky her story
a rare ray of light amid almost blinding
tragedy
governor andy beshear and his wife
struggling to come to grips with
kentucky's nightmare
these tornadoes would have marked one of
the most awful days in our state's
history no matter when they struck
that's even more painful that this
tragedy happened just a few weeks before
christmas
as a mom wife daughter and friend
i need you to do it
as a mom wife daughter and friend
brittany can only imagine the pain and
grief that kentuckians are feeling at
the moment
she knows so many of you feel the same
way and wants to know how you can help
make this season a little easier for
those that are hurting
a 15-minute drive from mayfield in the
town of wingo survivors are brazing for
christmas unlike any other at this
church turned shelter
we're pretty much going to be here for
christmas new year's and for his
birthday in this little shelter in this
church
but many here are just happy to be alive
you know christmas time you want to be
able to be at home enjoy the family the
holidays and christmas lights up and all
that good stuff you know what i mean but
i'm i'm just so grateful that i'll be
able to have my son for christmas you
know what i mean and
with over a thousand homes destroyed in
kentucky alone and many still without
water and power president joe biden has
signed an executive order to get help to
the affected areas faster
this administration has made it clear to
every governor
whatever they need when they need it
when they need it make it known to me
and we'll get it to them as rapidly
rapidly as we can
president biden says he will travel to
kentucky on wednesday
hoping to help people like teresa
herndon rise from the ruins
travis ragsdale is a journalist from
louisville kentucky we asked him what
the most immediate needs are for the
rescue workers
they have the supplies that they need
right now the supply needs are always
going to change day to day yesterday
people in this area that were affected
needed clothing well they've gotten the
clothing now now they need things like
phone chargers
because they haven't been able to charge
their phones because nobody has power in
the area so the needs are constantly
going to change so what these groups are
asking for right now our monetary
donations 100 of the donations are going
to these relief efforts so that then the
groups on the ground can have a better
way to get the things that are needed in
the moment and on that particular day
because the needs are constantly
changing